[Music]
john is there something in addition to
just um
maturity
emotional maturity
not not chronological or anything else
but just emotional maturity is there
something in addition to that that um
breaks someone away from a get rich
quick because i remember when i
got rich quick
i was chasing get rich quick nothing
down real estate and i did it i got rich
quick and then i lost everything because
i was stupid he who hastens to be rich
when i go and punish
but there's something that um
it greed and fear are the things that
drive that but it feels like that
um there there's a uh
this looking for a shortcut thing feels
like a maturity thing is it something
else
i i tend to think it's it's about
belonging um the way we're bombarded
with messages now
like we think about that last caller the
way we're bombarded with messages now is
that everybody's doing this thing
and suddenly you're put into this
like this it's like the titanic we're
all getting on the boats man if you
don't get on the boat you're going to
drown
and i think it's just this and then you
start walking down that road and then
somebody's like what about all this and
there's just such a machine that keeps
pumping things into you but you're not
doing what you could be doing
and i didn't feel like everybody was
doing nothing done really no i think i
think back in the day there was one or
two because i think about the old
i thought i was the exception that you
were special yeah yeah now i think it
switched to where you're left out
fomo yeah yeah and i remember i to
answer your original i
i remember back in it was 2004 2005 when
the ufc the ultimate fighting
championship started to blow up yeah and
gyms opened up everywhere yep and
everybody's a fighter i'd been a part of
a gym for a while and
they filled up real fast and then they
emptied equally as fast because people
realized oh they punch you in the face
this is not funny how this does hurt oh
they kick you yeah and so i think
there's something about
unfortunately part of wisdom is getting
hit in the mouth and i think you've got
to put some money into bitcoin and lose
every penny of it thinking you were so
smart and that's how you realize huh if
someone didn't teach you out of the gate
about humility and wisdom and hey we won
this this time but not this time
i think that's a real important lesson
either you confer that or you just got
to take it
if you don't have a model for it right
yeah but i'm just
the cause is what i was the root cause
uh from a psychological perspective so
it is fomo
it can be or you know if you're missing
out or it can be
um i think we're i think we're pride
that we're special or you know i'm
different i can do this but we're wired
to the least the the least restrictive
road right yeah this is the way we're
wired yeah and that that's not
necessarily a bad thing you don't want
to take a paint on to take paint on
that's weird yeah
but uh but this idea that that um
yeah i know i know 99 of the
millionaires turn become millionaires
this way but not me i've got this i've
got it yeah there's something just
whacked about that and i was one of them
i did that i fell into that it's an
arrogance of sorts and i talked about
this on the maturity tied with arrogance
on the on the documentary same thing
playing the lotto i had a history
professor who um we were talking about
d-day and i i looked at it he was a
strategist uh strategist a military
strategist and
i was looking at d-day and i was like
man
why didn't they just send 30 or 40 000
of our top troops into
into d-day and my professor's response
was because any
they would have looked at that and gone
this is not a good situation this is a
tough wave after wave situation
and i said well what kept all those guys
going they all thought they weren't
going to die and he said pure
old-fashioned 18 year old arrogance they
both looked at each other and they
looked at the right and the left and
said sucks to be that guy because i'm
coming home when they sit there and told
you eight out of eight out of 10 out of
10 of you aren't coming home i think
there's just something about being 18 19
20 21 you're invincible you're ready to
go take on the world and that opening
scene in private ryan oh man i stood on
top of that beach just looking at the
gun torch can you imagine 3 500 men died
on omaha in like 17 minutes instantly
yeah they just obliterated yeah
and uh yeah there's something about that
and we'll just keep going we'll just
keep going and that's what happens with
these waves of get rich quick as they
come through
and they come through about twice three
times a generation roughly
but i hadn't seen one like this one in a
while this one's very interesting
but um
because it's mixed in with this
existential crisis around
uh around covid where everybody thinks
everybody suddenly realized they're
gonna die yeah and so we're just here
for a vapor and you mix that with a
little inflation
fifteen percent no it's not seven
percent something right you know which
means he's been reading the gold side or
he's been reading a bitcoin site because
the actual inflation rate is not fifteen
percent
seven percent's not good but seven
percent i mean in carter we had 12 right
so i mean
i think it goes back to if
surround yourself with wise people
because they're going to be able to tell
you if their heart rate doesn't get up
hey yeah inflation seven if your broke
beer drinking buddies are all that you
have to help you analyze your wealth
building process you're screwed that's
right
yeah absolutely or if the internet is
the other only source you've got which
is even worse right yeah because they're
trying to make money off of you well and
you know worse than that they're wrong
you know it's just like it's that's the
other problem is it's just inaccurate
it's uh it's bad information most of the
time i mean not everything on the
internet's bad information but this idea
that there's like you know my generation
ascribed
uh my parents generation ascribed
uh
complete credibility
to any
news man on cbs
if walter cronkite said it
that's right there with like jesus said
it that's it it's done
this generation is wisely believes
nothing the media says
because nothing they say is true
um i mean nothing they say it's true
it's pretty it's like our local
newspaper if you read it in there you go
i wonder what really happened
every time i read it i read articles
about people including myself i go who
is that guy i don't even know that guy
they just made that up how did they
where did they get that information they
just just dreamed up a story and put it
in there and so it but it's just this
generation because so journalism has
completely lost credibility it doesn't
have that anymore but this generation
then
not this current one these 19 year olds
they're smarter than that but the
probably the millennials they think
everything on the internet was true
and so the big joke was you know
everything on the internet is true hey
but abe lincoln you know described you
know describe the quote table lincoln
and so uh but
you know but we're starting to realize
the source of information is not there
it's not true and so what you've got to
do is you have to get around people who
have proven
track records
of actually doing the thing you're
talking about that's right
and um if you want to be a really
world-class parent
you should not hang out with people
who have parenting theories right or
bonkers kids or kids that are all you
know off the dad gum reservation where
the in asylums or the inmates are
running the asylum but if you see a
family that's functional
and the children are not they're not
little step for children they're not
devoid of personality in the name of
discipline but on the other hand they're
not running around the restaurant
swinging from the chandeliers you know
they've got a personality but they
they're respectful they're also you know
they seem to be functional children on
the way to adulthood that'd be a couple
to sit down have dinner with and talk to
about how to be a parent because they
actually are doing it that's right same
thing with the marriage you know i got
to spend time with mr kathy before he
and ms gene passed away and
um i remember i was we were in long
beach speaking at this
speaking of chick-fil-a thing and we're
up in the suite with him and um
bubba and trudy and uh dan their three
kids and a bunch of their grandkids and
stuff
and i'm talking to him because i just
i'm enthralled at that point i think
they've been married 67 years wow and so
we're walking along the concourse you
know
down through here these
80-something-year-old people and i look
up and they're holding hands
and i'm like this is who i want to talk
to about being married that's right
you know one time 67 years yep i want to
talk to them about being married now you
asked you want to ask mr truth kathy
about a lot of different things there's
been a lot of things to ask him about
but i did i asked him and i asked her
because sharon was with me i said so
miss kathy how do you uh how do you put
up with a an entrepreneurial man like
this all these years
and she just those eyes lit up and she
smiled and she said
patience
[Laughter]
did sharon give her a name in sharon's
dancing yeah you're right
about why why is people in your life
good wise
this is silly this is silly this this
the way we're disseminating information
in our culture is completely broken now
this is the ramsay show